Heute im Rasenfunk? Der blickt auf andere Nagen.
Da ist sie wieder, die Liga Tour von vielen, das Lieblingsformat inklusive von denjenigen, die sie machen. Ich freue mich sehr, dass ihr alle da seid, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und was soll ich sagen? Heute haben wir wieder alle Ligen mit dabei. Serie A, Premier League, La Liga und die Liga ist mit dabei. Und deswegen begrüße ich als erstes Alexis Menuge, wie schön dich mal wieder in unserer Runde zu haben. Hallo, Alexi.
Ja, ich habe es wahrscheinlich schon darüber gesprochen, aber das abgebrochene Spiel Marcel Lyon, bzw. nicht angepfiffene, weil der Bus, der Lyonär hier angerufen wurde, wird jetzt nachgeholt in ganz gleichen Konditionen. Also im Start-Velodrom von Marcel mit Fans. Wenn Großhoch bis dahin immer noch der Trainer ist, wie wird er dieses Spiel angehen? Psychisch? Er wird ständig wahrscheinlich rechts und links schauen, wenn man dem Start-Velodrom immer näher kommt. Auf jeden Fall furchtbar, dass da der Liga-Verband, auch wenn Olympie Marseille nichts dafür kann, weil es nicht im Stadion war oder ums Stadion, sollte man schon mal hätte der Liga-Verband da symbolisch auf den Tisch hauen müssen. Und das haben sie natürlich nicht gemacht. Wieder ziemlich feige gewesen. Und das überwährt natürlich wieder mal ein schlechtes Image über den französischen Verein Fußball. Und das nur neun Monate vor den Olympischen Spielen in Paris, die auch schon viel Sorgen bereiten, was die Sicherheit anbelangt und die Organisation.
Okay, da können wir gespannt sein, wie dieses Nachos-Spiel laufen wird. Alexi, falls du los musst, dann herzlichen Dank. Ansonsten kannst du auch noch gerne... Bis bald mal wieder, ne? Und wir machen weiter im Moment. Jetzt bin ich durcheinander gekommen. Uli, kannst du uns noch einen Ansagenhero nennen?
Ich habe einen, der noch nie in seinem Leben besungen worden ist. Also wirklich die Definition eines Ansagenheroes. Den Namen werdet ihr wahrscheinlich nicht mehr gehört haben. Thomas Kaminski heißt der Gute. Ist Borderline-Kaderspieler Belgiens. Auf der Torhüterposition wird aber nie ein Länderspiel machen, weil es einfach zu viele Gute davor gibt. Aber ist der synkuläre Grund dafür, dass Lutentown überhaupt noch mit dabei ist. Im Irgendwas hat es sechs Expected Goals gehalten. Das ist ein absoluter Top-Wert. Ich glaube sogar in Europa. Ich habe es nach dem Spiel nicht mehr gecheckt, aber vor dem Spiel war es jedenfalls so. Hat auch gegen United wieder zwei, drei Dinge rausgeholt, die einfach gar nicht möglich sind. Super im 1 gegen 1, spielt super lange Bälle als Torhüter. Und kam eigentlich aus der zweiten Liga von Blackburn, wo er jetzt nicht total überragend war. War auch nicht gesichert, dass der die Nummer 1 sein würde bei Luten. Das hat Rob Edwards lang offen gelassen. Aber im Moment gibt es da überhaupt nichts zu diskutieren. Ist einer der leistungsstärksten Spieler überhaupt in der Premier League. Und den hätte ich genauso gut als MVP nehmen können. Luten hat einen Kader, der bestenfalls Mittelmaß-2. Liga ist. Sie sind trotzdem mit dabei. Das liegt zum einen am Trainer, der das schon ganz ordentlich macht. Aber vor allen Dingen an Kaminski. Deswegen muss der mal genannt werden. Und das ist ja wirklich Ansagen. Weil, glaube ich, das ist nie passiert.
Ja, absolut fantastisch. Hat vorher bei Blackburn lange gespielt. Und nein, das wusste ich nicht auswendig. Das wäre ja ein bisschen komisch. Dann kannst du uns auch gerne, wenn du willst, schon deinen Moment nachliefern, Uli. Was war denn so besonders bemerkenswert in den letzten Wochen?
Also der Moment war, als der WEA einmal richtig lag. Wir haben ein großes Problem mit England gerade. Aber im Ernst ist es relativ einfach. Und das hat jetzt gar nichts mit dem Sportlichen zu tun. Aber gestern gab es das Bild, das um die Welt ging, Louis Dias mit seinem Vater, der knappe zwei Wochen in Gefangenschaft war, gekidnappt wurde. Und am Donnerstag, ganz kurz vor dem Europa-League-Spiel Liverpool in Toulouse, ist die Meldung gekommen, dass er befreit worden ist. Jetzt ist ja Louis Dias heimgeflogen zur Qualifikation, also mit der Nationalmannschaft, und hat dann seinen Papa Davide getroffen. Und diese ganze Sache, so traurig zunächst der Hintergrund, ja, war logischerweise immer noch ein riesengroßes Problem in Kolumbien, oder generell in Südamerika, vor allen Dingen in Kolumbien, dass eben die Familien der Spieler total unsicher sind. Aber als es dann Gott sei Dank glimpflich über die Bühne ging, diese Momente, auch denen ging ja schon zuvor, dass Louis Dias ein Tor macht in der Nachspielzeit, als er ja für eine Woche circa raus war, ist alles nicht nachzuvollziehen, was da passiert, auch nicht nachzufühlen, also gar nicht zu greifen irgendwie. Und trotzdem dann so schön, dass es wenigstens gut ging, nach all dem Materium, das da wahrscheinlich passiert sein muss, also die Details, ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich die jemals wissen will, aber deswegen ist das sicher der Moment, das hat nichts mit Fußball zu tun, ist aber auch ganz gleich.
Ja, sehr schön. Siehst du, das hatte ich nämlich zum Beispiel gar nicht mitbekommen, dass es da jetzt auch die Zusammenführung der beiden wieder gab. Nils, sag uns doch mal deinen Ansang Hero und gerne auch dann gleich deinen Moment hinterher.
Ich musste noch überlegen, kann ich irgendwie noch Atletico und Basel mit reinkriegen? Ich glaube, ich kriege Sinn. Ich dachte beim Ansagen Hero vielleicht auch erst an den Ivar Racket hinstellen, wie es Sevilla noch hilft. Aber ich gehe mal zu Atletico. Denn dort gibt es einen, der wurde lange als Chancentod betitelt und auch belächelt, natürlich auch von Madridistas, weil er aus Real Madrid-Jugend kommt, aber Alvaro... Leider nein. Aber Alvaro Morata spielt eine Riesensaison, weil er endlich auch die vermeintlich einfachen Tore macht. Also mit auch Nationalmannschaft hat er in 19 Spielen 16 Tore gemacht, plus noch ein paar Vorlagen. Also er steht auch dafür, dass Atletico das beste Team im Kalender ja 23 bei in der Liga ist oder teilweise auch in Europa. Mitten im Kießmann zusammen, Super-Duo, er knipset endlich, wie gesagt, ist auch als Joker griffig, hat da keine Probleme damit, wenn er auch mal auf der Bank sitzt. Also er funktioniert gut und verdient sich da mal ein paar Gesänge und nicht nur ironische Gesänge, wie das vielleicht früher mal war. Und als Moment, speziell des Spieltags des 13., habe ich mir was von Barca rausgenommen. Die haben nämlich schon wieder ein extrem früheres Gegentor kassiert. Jetzt gegen Alaves war es in der 18. Sekunde, hat Samu Omorodion getroffen. Vorher, ein paar Wochen vorher in Granada, war Brian Saragossa schon nach 17 Sekunden erfolgreich. Und das ist ein Rekord, so gesehen in der Liga, oder das gab es noch nie, dass eine Mannschaft innerhalb einer Saison in zwei Spielen innerhalb der ersten 20 Sekunden Gegentore kassiert. Da hat jetzt Barca auch für einen kleinen Negativrekord, das ist für mich der Moment des Spieltags.
Aber waren denn das... Es gibt ja inzwischen so Spielzüge, die vom Anpfiff weg gespielt werden. War das so, oder einfach langer Ball nach vorne und dann gebielen?
Das ist das Lustige. Barca hatte Anstoß jetzt gegen Alaves und hat versucht, mit gleich sieben Spielern anzugreifen. Die waren alle schon an der Mittellinie, alle gehen vor. Alaves hat dann leicht den Ball irgendwie abgefangen. Oder zumindest in die andere, in Barca's Hälfte gebracht. Dort an Ilkay Gündogan den Ball ein bisschen schlampeig, müde verloren. Aber dann dahinter waren auch noch drei, vier Verteidiger, die dann auch nicht so griffig gewesen. Und dann tatsächlich Umorodi und, ich glaube, noch Testegen getunnelt. Also da hatte Alaves eigentlich nicht so viel mit zu tun. Das war jetzt nichts Einstudiertes, weil Barca hatte Anstoß.
Ja, aber das macht ja eigentlich wirklich noch lustiger, muss man sagen. Also sorry für alle Barca-Fans. Aber naja, wisst ihr ja selber auch, wie es gemeint ist. Dann fehlt uns nur noch ein Moment, und zwar der aus der Serie A. Christian?
Ja, der liegt in der Zukunft, aber in der sehr nahen Zukunft, das Gute. Nach der Länderspielpause gibt es Juve-Inter. Und Juve-Inter ist immer Juve-Inter. Das ist das emotionalste Duell in Italien. Und jetzt kommt der Punkt dazu, dass Juve ja auch es geschafft hat, an Inter dran zu bleiben bisher, was Milan und Napoli eben nicht geschafft haben. Juve ist eine Effizienzmaschine vor dem Herrn. Also Allegri spielt Allegri-Fußball. Wir haben ihn noch nie in dieser Ausprägung spielen lassen. Sie kassieren kaum was. Das für mich das sinnbildlichste Spiel war vor kurzem in Florenz gegen die Fiorentiner. Die Fiorentiner hat gemacht, getan. Juve stand hinten drin, aber stand gut hinten drin. Die Fiorentiner, Achtung Max, das ist für dich, hat 50 Flanken gebracht.
Hoffentlich haben sie 0 zu 1 verloren.
Ja genau, sie haben 0 zu 1 verloren. Diese defensive Stabilität muss man auch dazu sagen. Es fehlt im Moment Danilo, wo man dachte, das ist eigentlich der, der diese defensive Stabilität Juve gibt, aber seitdem spielten Rougani und der macht das hinten genauso gut. Also Allegri hat diese Defensivstruktur seiner Mannschaft wieder eingeimpft. Bremer, Rougani, Gatti, Köpfen hinten alles raus, sind aber auch gut organisiert. Das soll gar nicht despektierlich klingen. Du musst auch tief gut verteidigen können. Und es kann Juve. Und jetzt gibt es Juve-Inter. Juve ist zwei Punkte dran. Das Ding ist schon seit dem letzten Spiel vor der Länderspielpause angezündet in Italien. Es wird eigentlich nur darüber geredet. Deswegen komm in den Sonntag, 26. November. Da wird es in Turin brennen.
Christian Bernhard, du bist so ein gottverdammter Fuchs. Jetzt haben wir keine Zeit für die Matches to Watch. Und dann sagst du dir, das packe ich einfach in den Moment des Spieltags rein und lass alle anderen damit doof aussehen. Aber es sei dir gegönnt. Danke, Christian, dass du mit dabei warst. Danke an Uli Hebel. Dich kann man natürlich auch auf rondo.tv sehen. Werde ich alles verlinken in den Show Notes. Und danke an Nils Kern. Da gibt es natürlich auch mit Viva la Liga die neue Plattform zum spanischen Fußball. Danke dir, lieber Nils, dass du hier warst. Was auch immer das jetzt genau geheißen hat. Es hat mir Spaß gemacht oder es war irgendwie schön? Ich hoffe, dass das wirklich die Übersetzung ist. Ansonsten werden es mir die Hörerinnen und Hörer sagen. Danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Da draußen im Rasenfunk geht es bald weiter. Auf rasenfunk.de findet ihr noch ganz viele andere Sendungen. Empfiehlt uns bitte weiter und unterstützt uns. rasenfunk.de/supporterscluboder mit Blick auf weihnachtenkiosk.rasenfunk.de. Bleibt gesund, macht's gut, ciao. Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank.